All these years after its release, debates
around Donnie Darko's true meaning rage on.
Some elements can be adequately explained,
while others are ambiguous and ripe for interpretation.
We're here to offer insight — and lots of
spoilers — on both fronts.
Separating Donnie Darko's deeper meaning from
its surface-level narrative is crucial to
understanding the ending.
Superficially, it's the story of wide-eyed
teenager Donnie, portrayed by Jake Gyllenhaal.
Throughout the film, he struggles to fit in
with his peers.
From the get-go, Donnie seems to suffer from
delusions.
Combined with a track record of unruly behavior,
regular therapy sessions, and medication,
it's heavily implied that Donnie is suffering
from paranoid schizophrenia.
"Donnie is experiencing what is commonly called
a 'daylight hallucination.'"
Beyond the typical challenges of adolescence,
Donnie is plagued by disturbing hallucinations
of a six-foot rabbit named Frank.
He drinks, rebels, and falls in love with
one of his classmates, Gretchen Ross, played
by Jena Malone.
He also has a love-hate relationship with
his parents, Rose and Eddie, played by Mary
McDonnell and Holmes Osborne, and his sisters,
Samantha and Elizabeth, played by Daveigh
Chase and Jake Gyllenhaal's real-life sister,
Maggie Gyllenhaal.
But Donnie's hallucinations are part of a
tangent universe where doomsday is coming,
and time travel is real.
Using this outlandish premise, director Richard
Kelly's cult classic simultaneously tackles
themes of fate, religion, sacrifice, love,
loss, and loneliness.
Let's take a closer look at The Philosophy
of Time Travel.
It's the book given to Donnie by his science
teacher Kenneth Monnitoff,
The book was written in 1944 by wispy-haired
Roberta Sparrow, portrayed by actress Patience
Cleveland.
Sparrow used to be a science teacher at Donnie's
school, years before she was known as Grandma
Death.
The only way to make any sense of the text
is by reading excerpts directly.
"It's called The Philosophy of Time Travel."
"What does philosophy have to do with time
travel?"
"And guess who wrote it?"
Helpfully, the 2003 Director's Cut DVD included
text from the fictitious book.
The text provides a number of technical terms
relating to the two different dimensions Donnie
Darko takes place in — the Primary Universe
and the Tangent Universe.
The Primary Universe is the universe we live
in.
The Tangent Universe is a carbon copy of the
Primary Universe, which forms when there's
a glitch in the Fourth Dimension of Time.
"Duh."
"Heh."
"Excuse me, no 'Duh' is a product of fear."
In the film's timeline, this glitch occurs
shortly before the jet engine crashes into
the Darko household on October 2, 1988.
That's when Donnie first sees Frank in his
dreams.
After saving Donnie's life by guiding him
away from his house, Frank makes a prophetic
warning: In 28 days , six hours, 42 minutes
and 12 seconds, the world will end.
"Why?"
Here's the reason why: Tangent Universes are
"highly unstable" and only exist for a few
weeks.
Eventually, they collapse on themselves.
According to The Philosophy of Time Travel,
they form
"... a black hole within the Primary Universe,
capable of destroying all existence."
The events in the Tangent Universe that occur
from October 2 to October 31 transpire away
from the Primary Universe's timeline.
In effect, the Primary Universe is "on hold"
during the Tangent Universe's existence, which
explains the glitch in the Fourth Dimension
of Time.
Got all that?
Fortunately, there's a way the universe can
be saved.
The Artifact — which, in this case, is the
jet engine — is the key.
The Tangent Universe is a like-for-like copy
of the Primary Universe.
The Artifact is an exception that materializes
spontaneously after a Tangent Universe is
formed.
This object, made of metal, is erroneously
copied twice, and it's the first sign that
a Tangent Universe has formed.
It's the only difference between the two universes
and it disrupts the natural order of things.
"I'm not following you."
You see, in order for the Tangent Universe
to collapse safely after its twenty-eight-day
lifespan, it must be identical to the Primary
Universe — so the Artifact needs to leave
the Tangent Universe before it can collapse.
The only way to remove the Artifact from the
universe is to send it through a time portal
back to the Primary Universe.
To save the universe, someone living inside
the Tangent Universe must transfer the Artifact
back in time to October 2nd, 1988.
To clarify, there are actually three jet engines
in Donnie Darko.
Jet Engine 1 belongs in the Primary Universe,
still attached to its airplane.
The Tangent Universe forms, containing Jet
Engine 2 and Jet Engine 3.
Jet Engine 2 is correctly attached to the
duplicated airplane, which Donnie's mother
and sister travel on later in the film.
Jet Engine 3 is the anomaly: With nowhere
to go in the Tangent Universe, it crashes
into the Darko family's house — but Frank
manages to save Donnie.
Jet Engine 2 is later torn from the airplane
and sent back to the Primary Universe, killing
Donnie.
By the end of the film, the Primary Universe
contains the identical Jet Engine 1 and Jet
Engine 2.
But because the Primary Universe is stable,
it's able to withstand the anomaly of two
identical objects.
Donnie Darko is chosen as the Living Receiver,
and his mission is to return the Artifact
to the Primary Universe.
Why was Donnie chosen?
Well, as The Philosophy of Time Travel conveniently
states:
"...no one knows how or why a Receiver will
be chosen..."
"You call this clarity?"
The Philosophy of Time Travel states that
the Living Receiver is blessed with "Fourth
Dimensional Powers," including, quote, "enhanced
strength, telekinesis, mind control, and the
ability to conjure fire and water."
Knowing this helps explain how Donnie was
able to succeed in his mission.
But these powers come with a cost — the
Living Receiver also experiences hallucinations
and terrifying dreams.
"Who is he going to kill, Donnie?"
"I can see him right now!"
It's not only the Living Receiver who's affected.
Those who are close to Donnie subconsciously
guide him along on his mission, often acting
erratically.
Other than Donnie, all the other characters
fall into one of two categories: the Manipulated
Living, or the Manipulated Dead.
Most characters in Donnie Darko fall into
the first category, "the Manipulated Living."
They have an important job but know little
of it, subconsciously helping Donnie along
his journey.
"I guess people are just born with tragedy
in their blood…"
Donnie's fate is to kill Frank, portrayed
by actor James Duval, by shooting him through
the eye.
After Frank is killed, he becomes one of the
Manipulated Dead.
This is crucial.
Without Frank as a guide, Donnie would have
no warning, and no indication of his role
in saving the universe.
Anyone killed in the Tangent Universe becomes
one of the Manipulated Dead.
Their in-universe death makes them more powerful
than the Manipulating Living.
This is presumably because their spirits move
beyond the material world to a metaphysical
dimension, while they remain alive in the
suspended Primary Universe.
They're capable of time travel and, unlike
the living, have conscious knowledge of the
threat of universal annihilation.
Frank's influence is obvious.
"Why do you make me flood the school?"
"You're in great danger."
He commands Donnie to flood the school and
burn down Jim Cunningham's house.
Every action that Frank encourages has very
significant consequences.
Kenneth Monnitoff helps Donnie discover his
purpose by discussing wormholes, portals,
and the feasibility of time travel before.
Fellow teacher Karen Pomeroy, portrayed by
Drew Barrymore, plays Cupid between Gretchen
and Donnie, giving Gretchen this bizarre instruction:
Sit next to the boy you think is the cutest.
Quiet!"
After she's fired, she opts for more overt
tactics, like writing "Cellar Door" on the
chalkboard.
Well, after leaving a Halloween party, Donnie
opens a cellar door.
"Cellar door!"
"What?"
But after opening the door, he bumps into
bullies Seth and Ricky.
Why are they there?
Because they are among the Manipulated Living.
Once they've dragged Donnie and Gretchen outdoors,
the pieces are in place for Frank's arrival.
Frank swerves his car to avoid Roberta Sparrow
and ends up running over Gretchen.
The events in the Tangent Universe imply something,
or someone, is orchestrating everything behind
the scenes.
Graffiti outside Donnie's school reads, "They
made me do it," but who are "they"?
In the DVD commentary, director Richard Kelly
explains that the force, in essence, is God.
Throughout the film, God is represented in
the form of a glowing tunnel.
During therapy, Donnie refers to the tunnels
as:
"Workers… assigned to each one of us."
These "workers" first appear In Donnie's house,
leading Donnie to his parents' room, where
he finds the gun he eventually uses to kill
Frank.
During therapy, Donnie opens up about his
fear of dying alone.
Without discovering God, it sounds highly
unlikely he would have ever sacrificed himself.
"The search for God is absurd?"
"It is if everyone dies alone."
However, Donnie's direct communication with
God, in the form of the aforementioned workers,
comforts him.
Donnie utters a phrase to Seth when Frank's
speeding car saves him from the knife-wielding
bully:
Deus ex machina."
"What did you just say?"
"Deus ex machina" is in reference to a plot
device used in fiction when an unexpected
event saves a hopeless situation.
However, its translation "God from the machine"
has a different implication: Donnie knows
Frank's arrival is part of God's plan.
As they take a stroll through the park, Gretchen
asks Donnie:
"What if you could go back in time, and take
all those hours of pain and darkness, and
replace them with something better?"
That comment seems innocent at the time, but
remember: Gretchen is one of the Manipulated
Dead, since she dies in the Tangent Universe.
She was nudging Donnie towards his fate.
"What if you could go back in time and take
all those hours of pain and darkness, and
replace them with something better?"
After shooting Frank, Donnie carries Gretchen's
body to his house, stops off to kiss a sleeping
Elizabeth on the head, then drives the family
car to Carpathian Ridge.
An ominous twister-like cloud forms.
But what happens next?
As the plane his mother and sister have both
boarded travels towards the cloud, Donnie
chuckles.
On first viewing, it's unclear that he's using
telekinesis, a power given to him as the Living
Receiver, to rip the engine from the plane
and send it through the portal, back in time
to the Primary Universe.
The natural order of the universe is thus
restored, which means the Tangent Universe
can collapse safely, as Frank's countdown
reaches zero.
This collapse is symbolized by the past 28
days played in reverse.
Donnie's voiceover reads aloud from the letter
he sent to Roberta Sparrow:
"I hope that when the world comes to an end,
I can breathe a sigh of relief, because there
will be so much to look forward to."
The narrative then returns to the Primary
Universe, last seen at the beginning of the
film before Donnie is woken up by Frank.
Donnie sits up in bed, hysterically laughing.
Then Jet Engine 2, sent back in time from
October 30, crashes into his room and Donnie
is killed.
"Donnie Darko.
What the hell kind of name is that?
It's like some sort of superhero or something."
"What makes you think I'm not?"
In the end, Donnie Darko is a superhero story.
When he wakes up in bed after successfully
returning the Artifact, Donnie laughs because
he's saved the universe, and saved the lives
of Gretchen and Frank.
His impact reaches further into the Primary
Universe, too, with characters later recollecting
key moments from the Tangent Universe.
In The Philosophy of Time Travel, it's said
that when the Manipulated Living and Dead
wake up in the Primary Universe,
"they are often haunted by the experience
in their dreams."
In other words, they experience a vague recollection
of events living on in their subconscious.
In one of the most fitting choices for movie
soundtracks, an acoustic cover of Tears for
Fears' "Mad World" plays, which notably includes
the line: "The dreams in which I'm dying are
the best I've ever had."
It's an apt reference to Donnie Darko, the
troubled teen who sacrificed his life to protect
the universe, and whose heroism is only vaguely
remembered in the dreams of all the people
he saved.
Tune in next time, when Looper weighs in on
the many merits of performance-art troupe
Sparkle Motion.
"Sometimes I doubt your commitment to Sparkle
Motion."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.